the future is now and we're about to be
joined by our panel of experts who are
here to take us from these fictional
worlds we heard about into some of the
real science engineering and politics
behind them
Wade Gibbs is editorial director of the
climate Parables series at anthropocene
magazine and a former senior writer at
Scientific American and he'll be
moderating this panel welcome wait
thank you Amanda
coming up everybody all three of you are
willing contestants
for the science game show
it's so wonderful to see you know these
Parables come to life through the magic
of Storytelling during the break I was
hearing lots of conversations sparked by
these big Ideas uh now let's do a deeper
dive into the reality of these ideas the
real science there but also the real
social and economic challenges so let's
get started we're going to start with
Mark Albert Mark is the internationally
best-selling author of 11 science
fiction novels including the Doomsday
show
on sale here in the back at climate
Thriller published last October after
getting degrees in astrophysics and
creative writing
Mark became a reporter for Fortune
Magazine and then an editor for 10 years
at Scientific American where we had the
pleasure of working together
Mark's story was the very first one I
commissioned for the climate Parables
series and he cleverly wrote it in the
form of a podcast script
so I definitely encourage you to go
check that out read it in full at
anthropocenemagazine.org
so Mark dodging the apocalypse your
story envisions construction of this
massive space-based solar power plant in
geosynchronous orbit 22 000 miles up
that converts the sunlight it collects
into microwaves then brings it down to
earth 24 7.
to a array of antennas in a field or
floating panels up to 10 kilometers
across it sounds pretty Fantastical
where did this idea of space-based solar
power come from and what's the current
state of the science and engineering
that's needed to make it a reality well
thanks Wade well as the writer of
fiction I'm proud to report that the
concept of space solar power was
invented by a science fiction author
Isaac asima in the year 1941 published a
story titled reason in which he
described a space station that focuses
sunlight on photovoltaic arrays and
beams the power to Earth and for decades
afterwards this idea inspired scientists
who then thought okay is this possible
and NASA studied the uh the problem of
is this possible in the 1970s and then
again in the 1990s and the big problem
with the idea at least back then was the
enormous size of a station that would be
to generate gigawatts of power as you
said you would need uh you know
a power array that is you know
kilometers wide which should require
millions of kilograms of material and
components that need to be lofted into
orbit and it was just uh impractical at
the time but the amazing thing is that
within the past five years we have two
things happening we have uh the new
developments in photovoltaic cells and
new materials have really driven down
both the cost and the weight of all the
components that you would need for space
solar power and with the Advent of heavy
lift reusable Rockets you've also
decreased the cost of setting them up
into orbit so this is now spurred Aid
explosion if interest in this we have
not only uh in the United States but
China is planning to launch a
demonstrator vehicle Japan is involved
European space agency has a program
United Kingdom has a program in the
United States the military is getting
involved the United the naval research
lab is interested in this idea to power
remote bases that need electricity you
know out where there are no places to
get it
um and I think perhaps the most exciting
project of all is a team at Caltech uh
built the Space solar power demonstrator
one which is in Orbit right now it's 500
kilometers over our heads it's a 50
kilogram spacecraft and it is now
testing the components that you would
need so for example it's testing the
unfolding of a very Ultra lightweight
composite that you could use to create a
frame for hanging you know this power
rayon it's testing 32 different kinds of
photovoltaic cells to see which are the
best that would work in space for
turning sunlight into power and it's
also testing the microwave beam that
would be needed to transmit this power
to Earth it has transmission antennas
and also receiving antennas on the
satellite now seeing how the
transmission works but the idea is that
eventually you would direct those beams
to receivers on on the planet's surface
so basically within five years as a
result of these demonstrator projects we
will know whether this will work on a
commercial scale wow so it sounds like a
lot of the pieces are starting to
actually fall into place what are some
of the biggest obstacles or challenges
that still have to be answered well you
still need to Loft millions of kilograms
of stuff into space and that's expensive
right now launch costs are on the order
of about a thousand dollars per kilogram
uh what you really need to do is get
that down uh significantly so that now
you know that wouldn't be much more
feasible another thing you need to do is
you have to construct this thing in
space and it's so big you can't have
astronauts doing it like they did with
the the Hubble you basically have to
automate the entire process you have to
create
um you know autonomous space vehicles
that could put the um the pieces into
place the latest thinking the latest
thinking is and as you can see this is a
a concept drawing here of the alpha SBS
SBS Alpha which was John mankin was a
scientist who was involved in the early
NASA studies and now he has his own
company and this is one of his concept
drawings
um and and what's very interesting about
his ideas is they're trying to make it
as modular as possible make it so that
you're Manufacturing in large quantities
all the components so that makes it
cheaper but also have it so that maybe
each part of the thing has you know for
example each solar uh photovoltaic array
could have its own antenna for the
microwave beam and this way um there's
no one point of failure no single point
of failure
um you could have micrometeorites uh
destroy part of this and yet the it
would still deliver all that power down
to the ground station you know so that's
that's the thing and then the other
thing is
you we need to keep the enthusiasm going
for this project for for Big Ideas in
general because global warming is a big
problem it's going to need big ideas to
solve and it's going to need all of us
you know we can't rely on just
government we can't rely on just
business to do we all got to get
involved and that's why I started
writing books about this because I
thought you know we got to get art
involved we got to get that amount of
excitement and that's why I'm so happy
to see everyone here because it shows
people find this important and
interesting and they want to get
involved excellent thank you so much
Mark
great
now Kelly it's so great to have you here
because you bring another uh you know
crucial perspective to this discussion
with your deep expertise in climate
policy all right so I want to introduce
a little bit about Kelly Kelly leads to
non-profits Silver Lining which she
founded in 2018 to promote scientific
research science-based policy and
international cooperation on near-term
climate risks and on rapid responses to
climate change and before that she had a
successful career as a tech entrepreneur
you know you've worked with the ocean
Conservancy on Ocean climate risks and
with Lawrence Livermore lab on
Commercial prospects for Fusion Energy
which are two things you do not
typically see on the same resume
and you now serve as a member of the
President's Circle of the National
Academy of Sciences and as an advisor to
a startup then dress systems that is
combining drones with AI to help restore
natural ecosystems
so Kelly I want to ask you about Elliot
Pepper's story Victory condition which
envisions major project progress over
the next century and a half in two of
these areas you've worked on Fusion
Energy which Powers all of the cities in
Elliot's story and ecosystem restoration
which appears in the story as a
rewilding of lands right outside these
massively reconsolidated cities what do
you think plausible what gives you hope
and what do you see are the big
obstacles well I was really pleased with
the story that I got and also the
beautiful rendition of it but
um because I think uh both of those
particular things I feel quite bullish
about and Fusion Energy I started
looking at a while back because it
looked like a high leverage point for
clean energy of the future but a very
non-linear one because Fusion Energy is
always 20 years away
so um so I started working with Lauren
silvermore and they talked to me about
the evolution of what happened there
since they started in the 90s because
from the time they started till the time
I got there there had been big
disruptions in the technologies that
were inputting to their process which
were lasers and Computing and so in
order to create Fusion Energy you're
trying to create the conditions of the
inside of the sun
inside of facility which is a really
hard problem and at Lauren slivermore
they do it with a giant laser array they
accelerate the laser beams and then they
shoot them to a center of a giant ball
to a single point where they're trying
to create the conditions of the inside
of the Sun and so the technology for
laser is the technology for computing to
govern that process you know each time
it gets disrupted you get closer and
closer and so you know that kind of
disruption in materials and Computing
and things like those are inputting into
Fusion as we go along so and now of
course you have you know quite a lot of
money going in billions of dollars of
investment and I know some of the
investors in these companies and at
least one of them a company in Seattle
said they're expecting to make big
announcements in the next couple of
years
so we'll see but but I think there's
there's reason to be hopeful maybe not
in the next couple of years but in a
relevant time Horizon on that one
um on the rewilding I actually think
um I know Ryan feelings here and I think
that nature restoration and based on
what we know and what can happen if
you're um
if you're evidence-based and
um and looking towards the native
ecosystem recovery it's actually very
promising and there are even you know
efforts in people's backyards in LA to
bring in uh sort of native plants and
then they watch the native insects and
the native animals come back so I think
the real rewilding was also quite
optimistic too the part I was less
optimistic about maybe was you know how
much of the consolidation of people into
cities and that type of planning you
know all the way to the extremes of very
highly pre-planned cities like the line
in the Middle East you know which is 170
kilometer line that's meant to house
nine million people in a pre-planned way
in with clean energy and zero cars and
so I think um you know there are a
couple of things about Humanity one is
that there's a sort of organic
development to the way that cities
Thrive and San Francisco is probably a
really huge example of you know that
sort of organic piece that you need and
the second is that the consolidation of
cities I think this is a problem that
San Francisco has that hasn't been
solved is regressive it's very hard on
people especially at the lower end of
the spectrum so figuring so that part I
wanted to talk to the mayor and see how
she figured all that out
great well let's shift a bit and talk
about your work at Silver Lining which
has been focusing on ways that we might
intervene if climate change happens
faster than the world can adapt
in um another of Elliot Pepper's work
has acclaimed 2020 novel The Veil uh
postulates or talks about a
controversial attempt to Halt global
warming by putting particles way high up
in the stratosphere to reflect a few
percent more sunlight back into space
kind of like what happens after a major
volcano erupts and climate scientists
have been kicking this idea around for
about 20 years but now it's gotten a lot
more attention recently with the
National Academy of Sciences and other
groups calling for more serious Research
into how this could maybe work and
equally important what uh unintended
consequences it might have whether we're
change precipitation patterns or how
plants grow
or how willing countries are to cut
emissions as steeply as they possibly
can what do you think are the most
important questions we need to answer
about this kind of climate intervention
where you raised a lot of them and um
the first thing I want to say is that I
think for everyone in this audience
almost if who was alive since 1991 you
know if you've experienced the cooling
of the planet from this effect from a
volcano in Mount when Mount pentativa
erupted in 1991 and that cooled the
whole planet you're also experiencing it
now because one form of this effect is
happening today so the particulates and
pollution
um they waft up into the low atmosphere
they mixed with clouds in a way that
makes them a little bit brighter
collectively that's cooling the planet
so we have a dirty accidental form of
this going on already and one of the
groups that I work with and they
actually do technology work at Palo Alto
Research Center here in California to
look at how you might brighten clouds on
purpose to produce a cooling effect in
the cleaner and more managed way to
Wade's point there are really a lot of
uncertainties and really a lot of
questions as to whether you can produce
the effect that that you hope to and
what the side effects might be what
you're seeing here is that effect
represented in the streaks of clouds
that's created by the particulates from
ships from Shipping emissions one of the
things we're getting really good at is
reducing those particulate emissions and
so a scientists are anticipating that
our current cleanup of particulate
emissions will increase warming in the
near term
and so this is something we have to
think about in terms of the questions we
need to answer both for how this might
work and what it might what it might do
in this sort of inadvertent form now
absolutely thank you
so Ken let's switch gears Ken Caldera is
a world-renowned atmospheric and Earth
scientist who I've known for many years
uh your research group at the Carnegie
Institution for Science based at
Stanford University has built
sophisticated computer models of global
energy and climate to see how they
interact
and Ken has also published pioneering
research in to ocean acidification and
the effect of climate change on coral
reefs uh he's a long time advisor to
Bill Gates on climate and energy and he
now works as a senior scientist at
breakthrough energy which invests in
sustainable energy and carbon removal
Technologies
so Ken I want to ask you about Kim
Stanley Robinson's story glacial
elevation operations I portrays this
last ditch effort to Halt catastrophic
collapse of an Antarctic ice sheet by
Perforating it with holes and then
pumping the water out from underneath so
that the ice grounds on the Bedrock
below is there any precedent for doing
something as audacious as that and and
what are some other ideas that are being
studied for slowing sea level rise due
to Melting ice
um
well I think one thing is just to be
cognizant of is the huge scale of
Antarctica East Antarctica the East
antarctic ice sheet is pretty much the
size of the whole contiguous United
States and the West Antarctic and she's
not as large but it's super huge and so
as with solar power satellites scaling
things up to huge scales is really
critical and I think for that kind of
scaling uh you know the idea of
Automation and machine learning and
basically I think we need to get to the
point where we have the supply chain
from mining to robot generation
automated and I think once you get that
goal then you can do things like build
solar power satellites and do these
massive kinds of things on an hour and
Arctica but I think uh just allocating
the amount of Labor and capital today to
do that kind of thing would be really
huge I actually I think the one worth
putting the water on top to me seems
more plausible that most of the West
Antarctic ice sheet is
um the Bedrock is is well below sea
level and and the problem is that the
ocean is warming around Antarctica when
that Ocean touches the warm ice I mean
the cold ice you know it melts and then
the sea water is coming under and I
think if you start pumping the sea water
out just more sea water is probably
going to come in and so really the
challenge is to cool the sea water
that's around Antarctica and you can and
also putting the water on top will help
also so that would make but the real
melting is happening where the sea water
contacts the ice and really I think the
only known way
that people think you could cool see
water
say within decades or something would be
some kind of solar geoengineering
approach I don't think these kind of
local interventions would really do it
okay and robots don't need boots so you
don't have to worry about the boots
getting stuck right
one of the things that I also have to
say about science fiction every every
human artifact existed first in the
imagination and if anything like this is
going to work it's really up to the
fiction writers and the people with
great imaginations to lay out the
possibilities and then scientists can
evaluate whether it makes sense
okay so I only build on on your previous
answer a little bit and ask you about
this article that you wrote 20 years ago
now I showed it to you earlier today
this is an article Ken wrote with a
bunch of other famous science scientists
and they published it in the um in
Science magazine the paper was titled
energy for her Greenhouse planet and
it's been cited more than a thousand
eight hundred times in the peer-reviewed
literature since 2002 it's hugely
influential
uh so in that study in 2002 you looked
ahead 50 years to estimate uh how many
more tens of trillions of watts of new
clean energy the world would have to be
producing by the 2050s to meet the needs
of humanity and you surveyed a bunch of
the technologies that were then just
over the horizon including Fusion Energy
including space based solar power
including solar geoengineering I mean uh
yeah and solar
um bouncing sunlight back into space and
so now here we are in 2023 halfway to
2020 just about wind and solar energy
have been growing even faster than
experts really predicted but a lot of
things like hydrogen storage and nuclear
energy and hydroelectric power kind of
got stuck and fusion and space solar are
still just over that Horizon
meanwhile worldwide emissions just keep
on going up so today as you look to 2050
and Beyond what gives you hope that
humanity is actually going to rise to
the challenge of transforming how we
generate store and use energy
if you told me it was year 2100 and we
had a carbon neutral or carbon negative
economy and ask well what do I think
happened to make that happen I would
think it was low low cost fission power
that fission just seems like the most uh
plausible technology that could be made
cheap and run safely throughout the
world and so uh but I'm also a believer
in not believing my beliefs too strongly
and therefore I would want to invest in
a broader portfolio of things to see
what would work but I would you know my
bet would be on a vision power I'm all
for everything else but
uh
vision is something that we know we can
do and you know when solar was expensive
we created or really the Germans
thankfully created a big program to try
to bring down the cost of solar and I
think if we had a similar effort on on
Vision power
uh we could have a long long lasting
reliable source of electricity great
okay so let's let's ask quickly we have
a little bit of time uh just one
question here that was submitted by
someone in the audience uh how can we
get the funding in the asks we need for
these projects quickly enough
you want to take a stab at that now can
you work for breakthrough energy they
they have some funding yeah what's
what's really tough unfortunately one of
the things I've realized over the last
year is a physical scientist and
okay now start to see some of the
political process and you realize oh
that I used to think oh the policies are
made so that if actors self-optimize
under these policies it'll lead to good
social outcomes but now you realize oh
well the policies need to be in the
self-interest of the policy makers or
else you don't get the policy which is
why we see subsidies and not a carbon
price and so on and so uh
but so really we need to make it so in
order to get elected you have to have a
good climate policy and unfortunately
that also means
that you need to address a lot of
people's more pressing problems like
education and health care and feeling
safe at home and so on and so uh you
know climate is super hacked up in a
whole constellation of social ills
getting money out of politics would help
a big problem and one of many big
problems yes but I think they but I
think they have to get solved
collectively that I don't think you're
going to solve climate problem
if everybody's got bigger day-to-day
concerns well well so we had tickets
more
point of view I
look on the hill and you know so so you
sort of uh it's it's a make do
environment and within that environment
if you keep your expectations low
sometimes you get pleasantly surprised
and actually I think what's happened
recently with the infrastructure bill
and the Chip's bill and the amount of
climate investment that went into that
um and you know that there's a lot of
Genius in there and it's it's embedded
in red parts of the country in ways that
are producing quite beneficial effects
so I think there there are some ways to
do things where you can get money going
into the right places and then certain
areas like nuclear need more but these
are also been areas of bipartisan
cooperation so research and Innovation
maybe I'm a little bit more hopeful that
you know there are things we can do in
the politics even when everything else
looks bad yeah I mean we need to
remember what could possibly go right
yeah
and on that encouraging thought we must
conclude unfortunately thank you and
good night
[Applause]
[Music]